thank you be here I'm going to talk
today about some work in a paper by
myself in these two recent students very
proud of these two students by the way
Justin Dyer did some work that i think
will help people figure out how the
sample graph on approaches the target
graph on and some pretty interesting
yashu worked did most of the work on
this it's her dissertation and she is
now she's now at LinkedIn where they do
have a network to predict on so here's a
sketch of the kind of problem we've
devised to solve there's a network and
they're labeled vertices here at spam or
not spam most of the vertices are
unlabeled yes if you can imagine
Facebook and somebody liked some they
don't have dislikes but you know
somebody somebody has a goldfish and
somebody just hates goldfish and most
people don't say anything about goldfish
and then you want to predict you want to
predict at the unknowns using the labels
that you do know and the idea is that
people are likely to be connected to
other similar vertices of course there
are covariance you could put in and the
model will allow for covariance but as
usual if you're trying to model the
graph structure you study what would
happen if all you had was the graph
structure here's the one slide summary
of what happens a lot of those
graph-based predictions we found in the
literature we're linear in the nodes
I'll predict this unknown using
something than your combination of the
notes if there's a linear combination
you think somewhere there's a Gaussian
story there's a covariance matrix
because with a Gaussian your prediction
at the unknowns is a linear function of
your notes so we went looking for their
correlation matrix so let's find the
correlations that are implied by these
algorithms then let's replace those
correlations by sampled correlations so
we can actually measure we have a small
number of pairs of labels we can see how
the correlations really are on the graph
at whatever distant for similarity
measure and then we'll rip out their
implied correlations and pop in our
empirical correlations so that's that's
the idea that we're doing we're doing it
on small graphs in this talk I'll show
you small graphs bigger than factories
karate club but not that much bigger
than Zachary's karate club in her
dissertation yashu also looked at the
Wikipedia graph to the way bigger than
Zachary's karate club but not as big as
what she has it linked in and we got the
Wikipedia graph from David clinic okay
so why does this make a difference well
those semi-supervised learning methods
we looked at were based on the graph
laplacian the graph laplacian is
interesting but it's not a magical
object likelihood is Magic graph
laplacian is not magic and there's no
way that you could imagine that the same
correlation structure should be true for
people's age their weight their income
their BMI their gender all of those
things why would you have one
correlation for all of those possible
responses that can't be right and the
graph laplacian took the correlation
structure right out of the network okay
so that's why we think it makes sense to
pop in some empirical ones here's some
notation though there are edge weights
they could be binary or not necessarily
binary and then everybody has an out
degree and an indegree the volume of the
graph there's a response value at at
vertex I and the important thing in our
notation is to separate the ones that we
know from the ones that we don't know so
a superscript 0 means we measured it and
there are of those and without loss of
generality it's the first are of them
then the remaining ones are in this
vector y 1 okay so there's a small
number of measurements and a huge number
of non measurements ordinarily here's a
graph random walk given those edge
weights we can make a transition we can
make a Markov chain with the transition
matrix that transition matrix will have
a stationary distribution
we may have to add teleportation to make
that happen but will suppose that
there's a stationary distribution
famously called pagerank now an
important object we need to use is a
graph laplacian the graph laplacian it's
the out degree of i minus the diagonal
this is what you get along the diagonal
and then you get this on the on the off
diagonals but why is it even called on
the plaskon imagine that the vertices
are 1 to N and you have some function at
all of the vertices the graph laplacian
at vertex I is this weighted sum of
differences between I and its neighbors
if you imagine the simplest graph
if your graph would look like this just
connected dots then the graph of the
plastine would turn out to just be minus
a curvature at observation I and if your
graph would be a grid it would just be
like a sample laplacian so there's a
real reason why they called it laplacian
and it's quite interesting but we don't
we never believed that it had magical
powers so here's one of our starting
points this paper by joe at all and they
define similarity between nodes so
similarity it's your chance of starting
at vertex I and then going to j plus
your chance of the reverse strip if that
number is high then vertices I and J are
similar then they make up a variation
functional for how rough the numbers is
Zr and it's a quadratic term where you
wait things that are similar so if
they're not similarly you don't care you
you don't care if they have comparable Z
values and then there's this funny
division by square root of page rank one
way that's explained is if a vertex has
an enormous page rank then you don't
have to regularize its value of Z is
hard but if it has a tiny page rank then
you do want to regularize it a bit more
the criterion they try to minimize this
roughness and then there's a penalty and
the penalty is your predictions can't be
too far from this quantity y star and y
star is either the observed value plus 1
or minus 1 say or a default value which
might be 0 for all the ones where you
don't know okay then then you have to
choose lambda and they trade off it to
observation fit versus smoothness is
just a choice of lambda the result ends
up being a linear combination of Y stars
so they've got a linear combination
somewhere there's a Gaussian somewhere
there's a correlation matrix if you're
waiting things by a correlation matrix
you're doing what's called creaking
creaking was developed in the mining
literature in the 1950s by Cregan so
imagine you want to know how much gold
is there underneath that ?
and you've measured how much gold there
is at all these other points and you're
going to your guests will be a weighted
average of the neighbors you put a
little bit more weight on the 1.9 than
the 1.7 because it's closer you put a
little bit more weight on the twos than
on the ones because there are three
observations down here and there's only
one observation up there but you don't
put three times the weight here because
there's a little bit of redundancy so
what should actually be your weight well
if you can postulate a covariance matrix
amongst all the known and the unknown
then you can just predict by conditional
expectation so here's our queen model
the observation at a vertex or this is a
vector of all observations it's a linear
model we will use pretty trivial linear
models plussing iid noise plus some
spatially correlated signal so in this
regression we'll just have a regression
with one predictor and it'll either be
the square root of the page rank or it
might just be the intercept term our
noise will be independent you know so
diagonal covariance matrix and then the
interesting correlated part is the
signal so that's the part that says how
similar our different vertices in the
graph depending on how close they are in
the graph in the end I'll skip some of
this stuff we're going to predict at the
unknown by its expected value given the
vector of measurements we made okay so
that's how creaking works matrix algebra
it's in our paper I don't want to dwell
on that so now oh actually there's one
thing I do want to dwell on its back
here the coefficient beta has a Gaussian
prior with a variance 1 over Delta we're
going to let Delta go to 0 and that will
put a diffuse prior on the regression
okay so here is the CH a-- f method in
more detail they take the similarities
and they make a graph laplacian of
similarities then if you decide that
your noise variance would be scaled
identity the signal covariance would be
square root of page rank diagonal matrix
more Penrose inverse of the similarity
based graph laplacian then back into the
square root of the page rank and your
predictors are square root of the page
rank and your defaults are some multiple
of page rank in then you take the limit
of a diffuse you do creaking and you let
the prior on bearing become diffuse in
that limit you get back to DHS okay so
now we know what correlation they're
using they didn't have to drive it using
that correlation but we can find out
what they're doing it's as if you had
that correlation okay so it's a kind of
creaking and the correlation matrix
depends totally on the graph one size
fits all no matter what your response is
that's the correlation it also
anticipates that the response should be
nearly a linear function of the square
root of the page rank I could imagine
that not every response should be linear
in the square root of the page rank
another method at the same time belkin
Matt Viva and Nagi they take a similar
formulation but their quadratic they use
the graph laplacian itself they didn't
do similarities their penalty is only
the prediction you made where you knew
the answer minus the known value at that
point and there's a penalty parameter
lambda they don't force it to
interpolate after all some of those
labels could be wrong so you don't want
to necessarily ensure play they're also
doing creaking and we exhibit you know
what their noise covariance is what
their signal covariance is what
predictors are using they're just using
the intercept term and then they have
two limits an earlier work puzzle at all
for undirected graphs it's also cleaning
also you need this diffusion of it
okay there's more examples but in what i
want to show you now is what did we do
differently the zou at all paper this is
their correlation structure the other
one we call Tico nos moving it has this
correlation structure and what we did is
we kept the mean we kept this diagonal
matrix on the outside we kept this
diagonal added noise and we added an
empirical correlation some Sigma squared
over R as a correlation matrix we have
to learn that correlation matrix and
Michael wanted to know what are like the
loose ends or the areas for further
research well one one of the things that
we do is make a couple of slightly
ad-hoc computationally convenient things
and the room for something a bit more
principled than what we did we want the
correlation between two vertices with
similarity FR j well we use the
variogram we look at what see what's the
expected difference expected squared
difference between two vertices and we
equate it approximately to the observed
squared difference that's going to be an
extreme overfitting and then we smooth
it out and we move it out in kind of an
ad hoc way the model gives you this
formula the important thing is r IJ will
equate what the model says the videogram
should be to the actual videogram we can
back solve this plug this in back solve
for r IJ so we back solve and get a
naive thing we fit a spline to say what
are these naive correlations as a
function of similarity pop them into a
matrix the matrix might not be positive
definite we would actually like it to be
positive semi-definite and so that we
force it to be positive semi-definite
and just bonk any negative eigenvalues
up to zero we have an alternative
version where we just use a truncated
SVD rank 1 or rank 5 for the two cases
we looked at and then we do creaking
with that estimated matrix
Thanks right here are all these his
similarity and here these naive
estimates of the correlation for all
pairs of labels so it's really a mess if
you smooth it you get this red curve and
at very great similarity there quite
correlated as the similarity decreases
they become less correlated
interestingly at the minimal similarity
it pops up a little bit we thought it
might be monotone but empirically it
wasn't monotone here's that same red
curve again and after we forced the
correlation after we forced positive
definiteness on the covariance we got
these dots which aren't quite where the
red line is but they're close we ran
this on a couple of examples one of them
is a data set of UK universities the
edges count how many links did
University I make to University J so
maybe Oxford links to you a bunch of
times and you link to Oxford a bunch of
times maybe Oxford linking to you it's a
bit more informative than you linking to
Oxford you know I could link to Oxford
from my basement that doesn't make me a
great university so so they edged the
the directionality is quite important in
this case and the response is a research
score so somebody scored research
quality of these universities there must
be a bit of subjectivity and coming up
with those numbers but we take them as
given in our experiment we would
randomly hold up some universities maybe
ten percent of them or maybe ninety
percent holding out ninety percent is
sort of closer to what we're trying to
achieve then we predict the held out
scores find the mean squared error and
repeat this 50 times just to make sure
we didn't get a lucky or unlucky hold up
and then the methods we use are the two
that i showed you random walks moving
and taken off and then our empirical
correlation versions of both of them we
have two tuning parameters we've got a
pic lambda and sigma those methods only
have one tuning parameter but if you're
cross validate is still a fair
competition and in fact in the end we
found their best value of
they're tuning parameter and didn't
matter you could just argh men over the
space and they still didn't do that well
in the chicken off case it was defined
for undirected graphs so we symmetrized
the graph that should be a disadvantage
on the university data to scimitar eyes
the graph and you need to know what's
this default that we plug in for the
unknowns and we just use like a weighted
regression to get some default this
recall this is the thing that the random
walk method is trying to minimize and we
found empirically that it ended up
really liking the regression variable
square root of PageRank so the responses
on the UK graph came out basically
proportional to square root of page rank
and what that means is that vertices
with the same page rank are going to get
pretty much the same prediction it
almost totally ignored the similarity
here are some empirical results first
for the university data if you use a
random walk smoothing the first thing
you could do is just plain regression of
square root of page rank and if you can
hold out 10 20 30 40 up to 90 of the
universities and you can look at the
mean squared error in your predictions
and you will see that these mean squared
errors rise the more you hold out the
worse the predictions the red curve is
the random walks moving with the best
value of lambda that we could find the
black curve is if you just did a
regression on the square root of page
rank this green curve is our empirical
stationary correlation matrix using or
rank n SVD we also try to rank 1 SPD and
that's the dotted one and I rank 5 which
we thought might capture a little bit
more the tikka NOS moving it doesn't use
the direction of the link so it seems to
be at a disadvantage here and here is
just a regression on on the intercept
here is what they get with their best
value of lambda
then here are the empirical correlation
so if you pop in sample correlations you
get a bit of improvement a question the
measurements were trying to predict are
somebody's estimate of the research
quality of the University on a scale
that goes from about 0 to about six and
we didn't delve into whether those were
you know the true quality of the
university so maybe we're just modeling
how somebody's opinion varies across the
graph let's zoom in where 50 of the
universities are held out okay so if you
hold out 50 of the university's the mean
squared error for these two models looks
like so if you the baseline is just
doing the regression and not even
looking at the graph just regression on
page rank regression on the constant the
random walk algorithm improve this Bible
three-point-eight percent empirical
correlations make a bigger improvement
here's a rank 5 version and a rank one
version and we see similar we see even
bigger improvements on this side but it
starts off from something that's much
worse it left more room to improve
second example maybe it's a bit overused
if the web kv data from Cornell and the
response we're trying to predict is
whether a page is a student's webpage or
not a student's web page and then we use
a binary graph you're a cup sort of the
same kind of thing with the random walks
moving now because I'm predicting a
binary we're not going to report mean
squared error will report 1 minus the
area under the curve and if you would
just guess you'd hit this black line and
if used random walk smoothing you hit
this red line and it seems like well the
more you hold out the worse it gets and
the empirical versions are making some
kind of an improvement the t-con offs
moving this is the one that ignored the
direction of the edges interestingly if
you ignore the direction of the edges
you're beating this one that looked at
the direction of the edges
so so that was kind of a surprise that
ignoring the direction of the edges
would help you but maybe it has to help
you sometimes I think this data was just
from Cornell it was a few hundred it was
pretty small data set it was also
possible that we got the data from
Cornell when they had all the other ones
in it but I think I think it was just
the Cornell so here's here's similar
number so you can you can score some
improvements by using the empirical
stuff and and changing the rack from
full rank to rank one and five seems to
still leave you with an improvement okay
tell you a little bit there's some of
this these are things that y'all needed
her dissertation so she looked up some
examples in biology the trick there is
that they don't necessarily believe
their edges in biology and she also
looked at wikipedia where you're trying
to predict you're trying to predict
whether somebody links to the page for
France and you can so basically you're
predicting the presence of an edge as if
that would be a response on the graph so
she worked on some of those things
feeling issues you don't really want to
do an SPD on the whole and by n but a
low-ranked SVD would work and she also
implemented some Markov chain iterations
where you'd run a Markov chain with
killing and then use averages from that
to make your predictions let me see so
by now yeah but wikipedia graph much
larger than Zachary your much larger
than the UK University still not as big
as as a Facebook Graph Wikipedia graph
will fit on your own single computer and
as she started looking at well you know
sparse STDs and truncated SPD's here's
an interesting fact that she found so if
you would take one of these networks and
measure how smooth it is so here's a
protein here's a protein network
there's how the roughness it was one of
these roughness measures and then she /
mutes the data at random and the
roughness measure traces out this near
Gaussian and she showed a central limit
theorem this near Gaussian roughness
measure if you would randomly scramble
the labels so it's interesting that the
true graph is quite a bit smoother than
what happens when you randomize in the
protein world not so in a web spam
example whoa quite different in
Wikipedia every time you randomly
permute the labels you make the graph
much smoother than the original one that
was there was kind of an odd finding
that that she got that maybe these
smoothness measures might need a little
bit of tuning okay so i think i think
i'll i'll stop here and take questions
if there are any and thank you all for
your attention
in the evaluations he did it look like
the data that you held out was missing
at random yes some social situations I
can imagine that the data is not missing
at random so I'm wondering if you have
thoughts about how that would affect the
results wow that would like that could
look radically change everything and so
that that that's one thought I know
there are people that try to solve
watching you you spoke about this on
Monday and then people like Dean apples
and Facebook tries to worry worry about
these kind of issues and I really have
no no great idea how to solve that 100
notes and you hold out 90 of them do you
have enough how I samples so maybe we're
holding in like seventeen universities
or something like that will hold the
hold in set is actually quite small and
then there's some theory if you have 171
so you held in 17 but now you have 17
choose two pairs of differences well you
have a similarity measure for all of
them so the number of similarity pairs
you get actually grows reasonably fast
so we were kind of surprised that you
could do anything if you held out 90 of
your hundred and seventeen universities
and trying to predict but it seemed to
work reasonably well and then there's
some asymptotics we cite in the paper
that Peter Hall worked out what happens
if you try this kind of smoothing and
you have you know on pairs of data and
it's almost as if your sample size would
be like you know our cheese too yeah
so if I understand correctly you're
combining the laplacian kind of
covariance matrix which the empirical
covariance matrix right yeah so what we
keep is that there's a regression on a
predictor and then we keep that there's
a scaling factor a diagonal matrix on
the left on the right and we keep that
there is a diagonal noise but then we
jump in and we rip out the old
correlations and put in our new ones so
I wonder whether explore other ways of
combining them do this to me to be their
page I mean you have two components it'd
be kind of me in sync it's my situation
they're really kind of saga know then
yeah I want combining different day I I
totally agree we've only done the two
examples i showed you here and then
y'all did a few protein networks and
Wikipedia network but that's pretty
small sample of networks so there's a
lot of other things that could happen Oh
what we did no we didn't do that what we
did is we would we were even cruder than
now if we saw negative eigenvalue we'd
make it zero okay it was more of a
cutting on yeah okay yeah well that was
my question actually who are you listing
all the organizers or you cut him off
you see we're just taking the negative
ones and making them zero we just it's a
really procrustean we wanted it to be
positive semi-definite so let's do that
and we I think I think it's like the
closest in l2 norm to positive definite
so that was yeah so that yeah that
doesn't mean that it's the right thing
to do and and so there's these two ad
hoc steps one we ended up using a spline
with like you know I think a lot of
knots to smooth out the correlation
versus similarity and then we we forced
it to be positive semi-definite so those
are those are kind of ad hoc and maybe
there's something more principled that
could fit in
hey mr. partying in the continuum